a national Secretary of the Public
Services sector of the GMB welcome I
want to start with asking a question
reported by the British Heart Foundation
that there are now 230
deaths which are being
associated with the every week which are
being associated with the crisis we are
seeing in emergency medicine at the
moment what has gone wrong and why are
we in this situation if I can start with
you Julie redhead I know thank you very
much I think um it's important to
understand how the whole system is
working together at the moment I think
the first point is around demand and
demand on our Emergency Services is is
up to phenomenal degrees especially at
the moment we've seen increases in flu
we've seen increases in covert
Admissions and the cold snap that we
know cold weather is associated with ill
health as well and we've seen rises from
those as well and that's that's not just
now but sustained over a period of time
as well
I think the other side is the
constraints that we have around flow and
therefore occupancy within our hospitals
and our occupancy levels are higher now
than at most times of the year so we're
running at about 98 occupancy across our
trusts now the reason that we're running
of those at the moment would appear to
be mainly due to discharge in that we
are struggling at the moment to be able
to discharge patients into Alternative
Care positions and we know that we've
got a large number of patients who who
call the criteria to reside which is a
sort of a way that we can identify
patients who may be better cared for in
different environments and so we know
that we've got a large number of those
patients in our beds as well so what
we're trying to do is to is to
understand all those flow systems to
make sure that we can respond to our
most vulnerable and sickest patients and
the trouble with when we've got
occupancy in the hospital very high is
that the and the the a e Services
themselves become overcrowded as
patients wait in the Ed to come into
beds and that causes difficulty with
being able to bring ambulance Patients
Out off the ambulances and into the a e
departments which increases the number
of ambulances outside of an a e
Department that then has a consequence
on ability to answer calls because we
know that the call handlers then get
multiple calls against the same
instances people are ringing back to say
when can I expect my ambulance and our
response times are in difficulty there
as well so all these things are all
interrelated across the whole pathway
and what we're trying to do at all times
is to try and find Solutions and ways
that we can make the system more
productive I.E we can get patients
through our systems as well as as
possible and working with our partners
both in Social care and Community Care
and mental health care to try and move
as many patients as at the correct time
to meet their needs that they have
during their care period as well so I
think those are the sort of important
sort of background information that we
need to have undoubtedly that means that
our response times are difficult for the
ambulance service at the moment and I
know that they're doing everything they
can to try and improve those response
times both internally but again working
with Partners across especially with the
integrated care services to make sure
that we bring everyone together to try
and find those solutions that we need to
do and that includes increasing bed
numbers which is what we've been trying
to do across the NHS as well with
ambition to put seven thousand more beds
in for this winter and that we're on
track to achieve those both in real beds
and also virtual beds it's important
that we look at new technology as well
and those plans are there but it's not
just a question of new beds because
discharge we're going to fill those beds
so we have to do that with process
change at the same time
so we're working really hard to try and
improve those ambulance turnaround times
so we can keep the ambulance on the road
bring patients who are most vulnerable
from the community into where they need
treatment which will be into our
hospitals and that includes heart and
cardiac patients we've also worked hard
to try and protect those services such
as cardiac and stroke Services we know
that those patients have time critical
interventions which will help them in
the long run and the ambulance service
themselves done a lot of work on this in
making sure that we've got the right
codes and the right patients in the
right category so that we can respond to
those who are most sick as quickly as
possible I'm really grateful for the
support that our colleagues have done
around that work as well and so we know
that the the call handlers themselves
want to help those patients that they
know need those time critical instances
so that's what we're trying to do is to
help them as well to make sure those
remnants response times improve but it
is demand and flow which is our problem
at the moment
thank you very much for your answer John
Martin I'd like to ask you a question in
the light that we are seeing an increase
in demand on the service in my own
ambulance trust a 16 increase since 2019
in uh Demand on the service so um how is
the service actually keeping up with the
supply of Workforce to be able to
address that demand because clearly one
thing we do know is that the waiting
times are increasing in order to to for
patients to receive vital care good
morning yes it's really difficult at the
moment um in in terms of those waiting
times they've got longer and we can see
that in the National Data that is partly
about demand as we've outlined you've
mentioned 16 I look back over the last
five years nationally in England it's
gone up by 18 but I think really
importantly it's gone up much more
significantly in the hierarchy category
so what we call category one uh is is
way way higher than it was previously
above 50 increase over the last five
years so we're seeing a sicker
population who are calling us more often
and paramedic members of the college up
and down the country are working
extremely hard to meet the need of
patients but we're seeing less patients
in a shift than we did previously and
that all comes back to the flow and
demand that Julian has already outlined
so if we went back a number of years ago
we'd see more patients we're seeing less
patients that that causes a problem and
actually for our members paramedics like
myself working up and down the country
that's having a big impact on us and our
morale our ability to care for patients
and our ability to to do what we need to
do to keep patients safe
thank you um if I can um go on to ask
Darren mockery is there now a call for a
further reconfiguration of services to
be able to address this crisis because
it doesn't seem to be abating anytime
soon it's something that's been building
for substantial time as we've just heard
so is there a need to look again at how
the flows work within the system to
ensure greater patient safety but also
to ensure that people are seen in a more
timely way which we know is clearly life
critical
yeah well good morning everybody I'll
not repeat what John and Julian have
already said but just to pick up on a
couple of things so in terms of
reconfiguration or looking at the
current models that we have just there
across England and I've been working
very closely as a chair of the
association a Family Institute of
Executives with Julian and the national
NHS England team and we're looking at a
revised or a new urgent and Emergency
Care strategy and if you think about
what Julian said earlier on around
hearing treating seating traits or
hearing treats when we treat poor
patients over the phone and signpost
them to more appropriate care or we
indeed send a paramedic out to those
patients and then manage to manage those
patients in the community without
needing an emergency department
attendance that's very much part of what
we want to continue to do because if you
look at the figures year on year we've
been really really successful in doing
that and what we want to do is we want
to work with our partners across the
whole system as Julian says and continue
as much of that as we can as long as
it's safe and effective for those for
those individuals so that would be very
much part of the emergency case strategy
going forward and the other thing that
the association of family and
certificates has been working with NHS
England on more recently is looking at
in the new world post covet how do we
right-size our ambient Services now in
England to make sure that they are
capable of doing what we need them to do
because we can see that you know when I
think back to 31 years ago when I joined
the joined the ambulance sector or the
ambulance service we can see that we now
spend a lot more time on scene which is
the right thing to do because that's us
trying to make sure those patients are
managed more locally and in the
community but equally Hospital
handovered leads because of the flow
issue that Julian described have gone up
you know probably six or seven fold
since it was when I worked on on the
road and that is obviously eating into
our availability to then be able to
respond to patients in the community so
the piece of work that I'm working with
energy single run now and the things the
point you're asking is can we now look
at what model do we need to go forward
and how do we right size ambulance trust
for the future to meet the needs of a
post-covered world
I just asked you when we can expect
strategies
it's been another International examples
of really good practice which we need to
Aspire to
yeah so NHS England would probably be
best place for Julian best place to
perhaps talk about when that strategy
will be finalized and launched and
because um you know that's and which is
England's strategy in terms of best
practice internationally believe it or
not we still have a lot of best practice
internationally and I sit on the
australasia so Australia and New Zealand
and meetings are set on the federal
meetings out in the USA in a certainly
primary care of Canada Chiefs meetings
as well and a lot of those countries
still look at the UK for best practice
particularly around the hearing
treatment Century I think the Big
Challenge we've now got in the UK and
that other International countries have
as well to be fair is the flow the
hospital Handover delays and that
vicious cycle of them not being able to
respond to those patients in the
community you just need to go out and
look in the newspapers you know over the
weekend and you will see it in
australasia you'll see it in certain
parts of the US you'll see in Canada
they've all got this challenge around
flow as John said patients might sicker
than they were before and it's that
perfect storm I think most covered that
we're experiencing now
tubing writing and it's an important
thing about the strategies that we've
been engaging with people from all over
the different parts of the service right
down to the sort of consultants and the
nurses at the shop front to make sure
that they understand and get a chance to
to talk about the strategy and that's
true for the ambulance service as well
to make sure we've got the right
strategy going forward I think that's
also going to be linked towards the
recovery plan for the UEC which
um we're hoping to get out in January to
make sure that everyone understands how
we can recover that but Down's
absolutely correct when he talks about
International comparisons because the
the strategies also we've looked
internationally to say what is best
practice internationally and actually
I've been talking to a number of
Partners in different countries as well
because I think we do need to to look
around at all the different potential
Innovations and changes that we need to
make over the next five to ten years
because strategy needs to look at that
sort of time frame but the recovery plan
will be much of a source so how do we
Implement that and how do we go through
those so I think there's a lot that we
are learning from our International
Partners it is an international
phenomenon and any consultant so I talk
to my colleagues in other countries as
well and they are all struggling with
this overcrowding in EDS especially
but that flow issue that I talked about
already
I I haven't got a date but I obviously
we can try and get one back it's being
it's being written up at the moment so
we're working together to get that
written out okay early next year do we
think oh yes no definitely right
and and if I may Rachel Harrison what's
the impact on your members on the the
staff in the front line and and taking
the calls of these delays
and good morning everybody
um it's absolutely having a devastating
impact on our members and frustration
stress burnout exhaustion low morale
mental health
um our members are tired of going to
work every day and in some cases
spending the whole of their shift sat on
an ambulance outside an a e Department
with the same patient we've had examples
where our members have clocked off at
the end of one shift to return the
following day to the same patient being
on the ambulance with the crew they'd
left them the night before
now our members went into this
profession to become Healthcare
professionals to help the public and
provide patient safety they feel they
are being physically prevented from
being able to carry out their jobs today
and that is because of this knock-on
impact with Handover delays and waiting
times and the fact that patients can't
be safely discharged into hospitals and
when they eventually get to a job that
they can see on the monitor somebody's
been waiting hours and hours for this
call they don't know what situation
they're walking into they don't know if
that individual will still be alive they
have friends and families that are
screaming at them as if it is their
fault and these are the very individuals
that are not to blame for this situation
so our members have taken the steps that
they've taken to vote for action and
this is one of the central Parts as to
why they are doing this because we have
been raising these issues for years and
we have been ignored old as early as
last year we wrote to this committee and
we had a very supportive response but we
wrote with a copy of a letter we sent to
the government
highlighting we've come out of the
pandemic we're heading into the worst
winter pressures that our members are
reporting to us
and it fell on deaf ears nothing was
done and those issues are even worse now
so our members are exhausted there's the
high sickness levels amongst all
category of workers in the NHS in the
ambulance service and that is because of
the terrible conditions they are being
expected to work in and this isn't just
the Frontline paramedics technicians
Emergency Care resistors this is the
call center people that are having to
deal with this influx of calls and
screaming family and friends that are
frustrated and the massive increase in
mental health calls that they're having
to deal with because there are no or
they've been significantly reduced
access to Community and Mental Health
Services so the whole impact across the
workforce is impressive and our members
are pleading on the government to do
something about this now thank you so
much and I think the NHS Workforce
survey has demonstrated on every single
category that ambulance staff have the
lowest morale and also the the greatest
pressures being placed on them did you
say yes thank you very much Rachel and I
just wanted to follow up on what you've
been saying because as local MPS we will
work closely with Chief Executives of
the ambulance our local Ambulance
Service I'm a West Midlands MP I have
heard since the start of this year
exactly what you have been saying I've
been passing that on to government by
ministers West Midlands Ambulance
Service experience 44 000 lost hours in
one month
waiting outside hospitals and what has
really frustrated me is that like you
say no one has been listening you've
explained how you've tried to get the
voices of your members heard I just
wonder Professor redhead are you hearing
that message do you understand what
Rachel's saying do you understand what
I'm saying about what's happening on the
front line no no I actually do I mean in
my own a e department when I talk to
paramedics who come I can see exactly
those effects on them as well and
obviously I mean I talk to the medical
directors of the ambulance service so
absolutely I understand that and it's of
how we make sure that we get the the
right
um the the right Investments and the
right areas to improve in the right time
frames and that's what we're trying to
do the chief executive West Midlands
Ambulance Service said at the start of
the year that by August September West
Midlands Ambulance Service would start
to fail and I just wondered what then
happened when you get a message like
that what what action is taken that
would prevent us from being where we are
now with with members quite
understandably saying no one's listening
we have to take strike action
when I say work very closely with
Anthony
um because of his role nationally as
well and the action has been taken to
what we've died to try to has increased
the number of call handlers because some
of the problem originally was around
call handling and being able to make
sure that we can answer the telephone
call and so we've increased the number
of call handers by over 300 from they
were a year ago and that's also for one
one because there's a there's a link
here between 1 1 and 999 calls so we've
also got to increase the number of call
handlers so patients can get the advice
they need through 111 and that's those
have been increased as well possible
five percent as well so trying to keep
up with that level of demand around the
call handling as well we've also
um uh put in more focus in terms of
those Handover delays because that's
really what is what is having the issues
for both the ambulance Crews themselves
because that's they don't want to be
outside the ants they want to be able to
help people and so we've been working
with individual trust they've got real
issues with this is this trust specific
because if I look at data for the whole
of the West Midlands I can see that
Telford enriqueen which is where I'm
from has the worst waiting times is it
because
the hospitals in that region are less
good at discharging patients than other
hospitals or is it something more
complex it's always going to be more
multifactorial but there are hospitals
who are more challenged than other
hospitals and those are the ones that
we've really targeted to try and get
those improvements but we've also put in
worked with all trusts across the
country to try and improve that Handover
situation we launched a winter
collaborative where we're working with
each trust around eight different
factors that we believe would help to
try and improve that Services as much as
we can although again I'll go back to
discharge being the number one that we
need to do and obviously we've got the
discharge task force which is led by
Sarah Jane Marsh and also the a new
board set up with nhse led by Leslie
watts to really look at this work around
the the discharges and the discharge
task was has had some success working
with parts of the discharge process
they've got the most control over and
we've seen improvements in the numbers
of
from that clinically reason to reside
where we can see some improvements in
those and we've now got a specific
challenge out with Community Trust and
also with local authorities to try and
help that position and obviously the
government have released more money into
into the local authorities to try and
help with those discharges as well so
there is work that is ongoing all the
time to try and improve those situations
John Martin can I ask you what would you
like to see happen
around these delayed discharges and the
other factors that preventing ambulance
paramedics from doing their work yeah so
talking to our members hospital
handovers is right at the top of the
list of their issues if we look at the
situation report uh most recently
published by NHS England on the 11th of
December there was 4 232 hours lost in
one day outside hospital and that
equates to 176 ambulances that is our
members who are really struggling
because they as Rachel says can't spend
the whole of their shift outside outside
of a hospital waiting to hand over a
patient that has a huge impact on
paramedics who are in the back of the
ambulance has obviously a huge impact on
the family and and the patient
themselves we we pride ourselves going
back to International comparisons on on
having great paramedic education in this
country we are we are considered at
World leading in our on our degrees how
we create paramedics it's really
frustrating then you can't use those
skills on on patients across the course
of your shift because you're with one
patient should waiting outside of a
hospital also true really that our
training is about emergency care about
urgent care about providing for that in
the community that's quite different to
the education of looking after someone
for hours at a time outside of a
hospital so it's having a huge impact on
morale having a huge impact on patients
and you can see everybody is frustrated
including the Ed doctors that they that
we then hand over to is this the real
underlying driver of tomorrow's strike
so we're a professional body not a trade
Union but I think in terms of what our
members are telling us uh the
frustration is that they they are worn
out they're tired and they want to get
back to being good paramedics
I'm sorry um Darren I wonder if I could
just ask you what else would you like to
see happen to improve this situation
that we've just heard so so eloquently
described
I think in in the short term we have to
thank
to unblock the floor
um and we need to find a way to get
ambulance patients handing over other
patients and that is easier said than
done and as you allude to some areas can
do it better than others and the work
that I'm doing with the association of
ambulance Chief Executives Julian and
others is how do we share that best
practice across all parts of the country
to see if we can reduce some of that
unwanted variation so there's a big push
to do to do that even the trusts
actually or even the ambulance regions
that had relatively good Handover delays
over the last few years include
Northwest ambulance service where I'm
also the chief executive that's starting
to get worse and worse and worse now as
well because of this flow issue so for
me it's about how can we get ambulance
Crews freed up quickly so we can respond
to the next patient and that's the short
term there's a big piece of work and a
lot of work going on just now around
Frailty Falls and mental health because
those are a huge volume of work now
within the ambulance sector so again
working with NHS England and colleagues
around how can we perhaps ask mental
health trusts and Community trusts to do
more to support some of those lower
Acuity patients that are falling Nine
and Nine because they don't feel as an
alternative because that would take some
of the pressure off the ambulance sector
to allow us to get to those heart
attacks and strokes and the patients
that we talked about at the beginning of
the meeting and in the longer term or
medium to longer term we absolutely have
to know right size the ambient sector
for the future and continue to look at
that Innovation and international best
practice for and our staff and our
patients deserve it you know and I hear
what Rachel was saying there about how
staff are feeling and I hear that every
single day I go out and do either a
clinical shift as a paramedic or when I
go out or I had to do station visits and
and it is you know it's so destroying it
really is for our staff just now in the
short term do you foresee that this is
going to continue to deteriorate this
situation
yes I I I cannot see how in the next few
weeks and months ahead that the
situation will improve
thank you James
um can I just ask about targets response
time targets um I mean they were
introduced three or four years ago
um I don't think they've been met
consistently since they were actually
introduced
um do we would it be useful to not have
targets or targets actually
been a factor of complication
um yeah targets have a an interesting
effect on paramedics so they've they've
changed a number of times in the 20
years I've been a paramedic
um we pride ourselves on providing good
care and you need to have a way of
monitoring that at the beginning of the
session we mentioned the British Heart
Foundation report for some conditions
time plays a huge factor and therefore
monitoring time is absolutely important
is it the only thing that we should
monitor and get hung up on I think the
answer to that is is no and paramedics
will tell you that time is important but
it's not the only Factor
what else should we be putting into
those because it's at the moment it's
purely to do with response time are we
hitting it or not and that has an effect
on public perception too so yeah so um
NHS England and Julian might want to
comment do you have another set of
indicators the clinical quality
indicators so if we take something like
a heart attack so where you you're
phoning up with chestplane we look at
the response time we also look at once
the primary arrives today give analgesia
so pain relief do we take the patient to
the right location because often for
patients who are having a heart attack
it's not to the Local District General
Hospital somewhere so there are other
bundles that are used they're often not
reported on though but time Still
Remains a factor in that so I think it's
both I think you have to have both
that's right do we need do we need
targets it's important but if we got rid
of them it's important I think to
remember where the targets came from
because they came from a process and
colleagues will know more about this
necessarily than I do so I'll do my best
but correct me if I'm wrong whether it
was a clinically LED position where they
reviewed lots and lots of different
ambulance calls in 2015 I think it was
through a long process to look at what
the target time should be for different
types of categories so the category one
response time of eight minutes is
important because that's how fast we
need to get to for patients who may have
a cardiac arrest to increase survival
times and that's also true when we look
at some of the category 2 response calls
as well so there are there are
conditions which do rely on that time
and it's important that the public have
confidence as best that we can to give
them that confidence that they will get
the responses that they would expect if
the targets have been consistently not
met over a long period of time and we
may have the argument that actually
they're calibrated wrongly doesn't that
actually undermine public confidence
unnecessarily in that it sets an
expectation that the system is just
simply not going to meet
and I understand your point and but I
think it's also important that we
continue to strive to improve our
services all the time and where there
are time critical interventions required
then I think we do need to make sure
that we're meeting those
um so I think that the time standards I
think are right it's always nice to look
at some outcome measures as well but
that's very difficult sometimes when the
public want to know exactly what they
could expect and that can be complicated
sometimes if we go into more complicated
types of monitoring for those Rachel
what did what does your members think
about targets
unfortunately because of the Staffing
crisis and the um Demand on resources
targets are just a number now because
they know they can't meet them
regardless of how much effort they put
into their working day they know they're
being prevented for meeting the targets
and I think the reason for that is you
know demand for ambulances has risen 10
times faster than the level of resources
so it's just becoming impossible to
possibly meet all the demand that the
public are wanting from their Ambulance
Service we we've seen coal volumes go up
by 80 percent since 2010 and when you've
got 133
000 vacancies across the entire NHS that
just aren't the individuals there to be
able to respond to all those calls that
are coming in
um category it was mentioned earlier
about the the increase in cat one calls
what category two calls have gone up as
well and they've gone from 25 minutes to
an average of 48 min it's in two years
and that is actually leading to more
debt during patient transport we're
going to be writing to the Secretary of
State about some information we've got
on that but these delays are impacting
on patient debt and we have to tackle
the root cause of this which is the
workforce issue which ultimately comes
down to their pay and their working
conditions
I wanted to come and talk about this a
number of you have spoken about the the
change in nature of demand and I just
want to ask Darren
um
is it possible that we are categorizing
too much into category one and category
two when we actually are triaging calls
so
even though demand's going up
the composition of that demand is being
skewed because of decisions at the
triage point
yeah just offices what do you think yeah
just before I answer that point I just
wanted to come back and the last
question you asked around the targets
and I think it's probably fair to say
that if you look at just after in the
ambulance response program which is new
targets that Julian referred to that I
think would start to be looked at right
about 2015 just prior to covert actually
many ambulance trust where achieving
those standards and in fact I know in
the Northwest there were a couple of
weeks throughout the middle of covert
when demand came down and the actual
resource was on that we actually had
made all our targets for if it wasn't a
day it was a couple of days but that's
unfortunately not being able to be
sustained for all the reasons that we've
just spoken about just now as Julian
says there was a lot of work done trying
to look at having clinical operate
Targets in terms of response times and
also the ambulance quality indicators
which leads to whatever the clinical
outcomes in terms of triage and there
are two um primary triage systems used
in the in the UK one is NHS Pathways and
one is mpds which is a an American
product and I think about half and half
of the ambient services in the UK the um
use use those two products and we've
been looking at how do we continue to
refine those products to try and make
sure that with a non-clinical call
handlers we do an amazing job under
Relentless pressures we've heard from
from Rachel sorry can I just just on
that do you think the pressure might be
leading to to the easy categorization of
calls into one and two
is that a consequence of the pressure
well I wouldn't say I wouldn't say that
because the call handlers are trained to
follow the algorithm and to go through
the scripts so they wouldn't deviate
from that unless we're you know unless
they were they were told about a
clinician in the room but even at that
they're likely to go through the whole
script because they're audited on that
so I don't think that I don't think
anybody's trying a new one I know you're
not saying this but nobody's doing a
shortcut to try new three Ash calls
differently but what I think we have
seen and somebody said earlier on one of
the witnesses is we are seeing much more
sicker patients as well we've seen a lot
more sicker patients in that category
one and two basket which is driving up
those those numbers if I'm being honest
we've also introduced in addition to our
highly trained and call handlers we've
introduced many more clinicians into
control rooms as well over the last few
years so that could be mental health
nurses it could be midways it could be
paramedics it could be general nurses
with review to support their call
handlers to triage those patients the
best we can so we're putting a lot of
emphasis and support into the into the
call centers but it's just not enough
with the volume of coals that we're
receiving just now and it's the knock-on
effect of the duplicate calls that's
causing the problem because if we can't
get the vehicles freed up in the
hospital to respond to patients in the
community we may be taking you know
several thousand additional duplicate
calls which is blocking the whole thing
up just just as a fancy I think there's
a couple of references to the fact that
you're getting an increase there's an
increased number of calls related to
mental health uh of a variety of sorts
um how do you think they should be
handled I mean how does it work at the
moment
if somebody if somebody presents
through the call system with say an
acute mental health issue in crisis
does that get triaged out somewhere else
or
is it handled directly by by the
ambulance service or there are they in
the kind of gray area
so does that start a question for me
sorry yeah sorry Darren yeah just yeah
yeah no problem and so so we will triage
mental health Frailty Falls and all the
same as we would with any other call
that we come in through the 99 system
our call handlers were taken through the
particular cards on the on on the call
handling TI system and they would then
come out with certain dispositions at
the end of that so it might be that
there's an immediate effect to life it
comes out as a cat one call and we would
immediately dispatch an ambulance it
might come out a more law Acuity call in
which case we might ask one of our
clinicians in the clinical Hub within
the control center to look at that call
take a mental health patient as an
example they may phone the patient back
increasingly however what we're seeing a
lot of the calls coming into the ambient
service for framity Falls mental health
could be dealt with more appropriately
by other parts of the system so what
we're working really hard with orange
now with NHS England and our other um
and mental health and Community
colleague Partners is how can we perhaps
because those pieces much quicker to
Mental Health crisis lines the Mental
Health Community teams to Falls teams to
Community Services because if we if we
can't do that then it overwhelms the 99
ambulance service and then we can't
respond to those higher Acuity patients
so there's a lot of work that Julian
perhaps could talk about in a minute
that's going on just now to see what
more we can do to set up and establish
much more robust and when I mean robust
what I mean by that is available you
know 24 7
um responses so when we need them they
can respond
etc etc so that takes a bit of the
pressure off the 999 system okay
thank you thank you I mean there has
been a session of a specific emergency
uh number for mental health so that may
be one of the solutions in that Caroline
I'll bring you in now thank you I want
to ask John a question before I do I
have to mention that I have been out in
ambulances before as part of my
pediatric work mostly on neonatal and
occasionally on pediatric transfers
um as a clinician back then so
um you talked about I've done about 176
ambulances being lost to time waiting
outside Amy was time frame is that over
and what sort of proportion of the
overall ambulance stock in that
particular shift would that be yeah so I
took the the latest situation report um
published by NHS England on the 11th of
December so that was 4232 hours over a
24-hour period so I've just divided by
24 to get to 176 ambulances say uh
arguing sets across the country I think
Lucy pointed out earlier that it ranges
around the country uh I think we need to
ask Darren about the total number of
ambulances on uh but I think what we do
know is that 176 ambulances uh we'll see
Circa 2 000 patients between them
because we know that you'll see five to
six in a 12 hour shift so you can do you
can do the the multiplication there
um and I think it is it is the
frustration of our members about being
stuck that actually you want to be back
out and helping and that is exacerbated
by
um with the demand that's coming in we
we rightly and ambulance services then
do what's called a general broadcast so
as a paramedic you can hear that there's
patients waiting that has a real
impacting we might call it moral injury
if you look at some of the literature on
people who are who are now wanting to be
able to leave one patient and start with
another one and they're hearing those
calls waiting and being held that's
having a huge impact an even bigger
impact on those who are working in our
Emergency Operations centers because
they are seeing the stack of patients
waiting and we've just talked about
clinical triage and how difficult that
can be in those situations okay I guess
the question is if these um I I
understand the frustration of waiting at
them that must be an awful experience um
is 167 in this context sufficient to
resolve the problem in other words if we
resolve the flow problem would 176
ambulances that you're losing
um cover the calls that you needed to
provide a really good service is the
ambulance service well resourced
but but the flow problem causing or is
it a joint problem that's the guess the
question I'm getting it
I don't think it's the single solution
to the problem
um uh 176
um if you went with basic maths of 2000
multiplied it out across the month you'd
probably get about 60 000 the increase
we've seen uh in the last five years is
about a hundred thousand extra
incidences in a month so it will still
be short and I think the other important
thing about flow and response times is
absolutely that you need to have some
spare capacity that's what we need with
beds it's what we need with 80
departments and that's because various
happens during the day when we go when
we go shopping
um if four of us turn up at the shop at
the same time there's only one cashier
it takes us longer if there's if we go
in one way one it will be shorter
response times and I think that so that
variation has to be played in so it is
certainly part of the solution if we can
free up that um it takes three years to
train a paramedic thyroid degree routes
so we've got good recruitment pipeline
lots of people want to be paramedics in
the country we don't have a problem
um recruiting people into the profession
but it takes a while to recruit them and
we have seen an increase in the numbers
of paramedics over the last uh 20 years
certainly lost decade so there are more
paramedics than there's ever been
working across the whole of the NHS and
outside of the NHS actually so I think
that the the there's a very positive
story about what paramedics have become
uh but I think that the Handover delays
is is one part of the solution thank you
it's really interesting
um part of this strike planning has been
what do we do and how do we replace
capacity because I don't think anyone
wants to see people lying on the
pavement suffering and cold because
there's no ambulance there because the
ambulance people are on strike um
and one of the suggestions has been
reading about was that some of these
ambulance will be replaced with taxis
um I wonder what your thoughts on that
are and particularly
ambulances you know you're in an
ambulance you get your team members of
Staff your paramedical or technical
staff
you've got a whole box of really quite
clever kids in the back there
um if you can replace that with a taxi
for a strike
does that mean that some of the people
who are currently using the the kind of
the whole
the whole the whole bells and whistles
the whole um Kick don't actually need
that and could we replace that kit with
taxis other times enabling paramedics be
freed up to see the patients that really
really need the homeworks
so I think it's you can't replace
paramedic with a taxi and I think what
we we need to get into so paramedics uh
registered professionals as you say uh
currently they've got a whole range of
uh drugs equipment uh monitoring that we
can do with patients as well as that
clinical assessment and getting to a
point I think they did what will happen
uh in terms of putting a patient in a
taxi uh presuming that they don't need a
critical intervention there and then
they'll be conveyed to hospital where
actually it might be a paramedic in the
hospital who sees them who does the same
uh the same scope of practice as we
would do pre-hospital what that will
have is a huge impact on on hospitals we
know over the last five years that our
conveyance rates um have uh dropped
we're essentially taking about the same
number of people to hospital as we were
previously from the ambulance service
primaries working in the ambulance
service uh whereas uh demand overall has
gone up and that's because our C and
treat rates are how often we don't
convey people at hospital because we've
done an assessment obviously someone in
taxi is not going to be able to do that
assessment they are going to get taken
hospital that put more demand uh on an
overwhelmed emergency departments so I I
don't think it is it is replaceable the
question is is what's the model do we
want paramedics out there seeing a whole
range of patients which we do do from uh
life-threatening to uh more Urgent Care
type conditions and we are able and we
are trained and educated to assess those
in the in the community and that's what
we're doing and that is keeping
ambulance conveyance rates
um not going up exponentially in the way
we have seen uh 999 calls up so do you
so just to clarify you think that at the
moment all of those people are going in
our Midlands Hospital need need the
whole ambulance to go to hospital they
don't that is not simply a
physical moving one person from until
from one place another because they
couldn't otherwise get there so those
that are taken to hospital where a
paramedic is assessment I believe do
need to be taken to uh by Hospital in
our current setting and that's because
they'll either need further tests
further examination uh often uh needing
a state stay in hospital uh is there
more that we can do in terms of our
educational paramedics that has been
happening in recent years and will
continue to happen to continue to bring
the the conveyance rate down
um there's a plan to use taxis unsafe
I think safety is a I've been artists A
lot of times in recent days we like to
frame it as a binary concept a safe and
unsafe and you'll know because you work
in clinical medicine but um it's it's
not either safe or unsafe do I think
taxis are far less safe than using a
paramedic in an ambulance absolutely so
and I so so for some patients it might
be okay for it but for a group of
patients they're not going to get
assessed they're not going to get
analgesia
um so pain relief they're not going to
get an assessment and they might be then
conveyed unnecessarily at hospital
whereas we would have been able to look
after them in the community
okay
um
that's right head um I wanted to ask you
about the
flow issue how when people get to
ambulance they're queued up and
sometimes I look at my office when
they're not doing a clinic and I can see
um work at Peter Hospital like if you
see the queue outside the window um of
people waiting um
that's very frustrating for staff
and actually quite you know custom labor
intensive you have a patient you may
have slept and fallen in the streets
mainly treatment or maybe the head have
some gas that they need to start saying
back up again
um he's got two members of staff and a
whole box of tricks in the ambulance
taking up all that time sometimes as
Rachel says for many hours
um
is there are there any alternatives I
mean we've talked about social care and
the issues of the overall flavor but are
there any other alternatives to to that
being used for example
saying to one ambulance crew to come
into the hospital building and then hand
over to another so you've got two Crews
looking after one patient so that you
know because one-to-one is routine prior
to you and most of these patients are
not that sick so are there other ways of
using these paramedic experts
um better perhaps just inside the
hospital but not handed over to the
hospital teams to get more of these 176
ambulances back on the road
the answer is yes and that that's
something that the ambulance service do
in conjunction with the hospitals
because
um but the difficulty is when you've got
a very overcrowded a e department and
space becomes absolutely critical space
the physical space to be able to place
patients in a safe environment and again
it's this risk balance between the
different safety factors of being in the
back of an ambulance being in a corridor
being an overcrowd in any being on a
ward or putting more patients on woods
so there's always this this factor of
balancing those risks across the system
that we need to do in the ambulance
service help us with that as they come
so we do our we would always try and
release Crews and I know every hospital
wants to release the cruise it's not
something they want to do and certainly
um the the staff within the hospital
don't want that position either
and I think some of this also is to do
with how we can get alternatives to the
a e and so that ambulance Crews can go
to other other calls so we've heard
about the full service and care for
patients who may need who have no
injuries as a result of their fall and
use of the Urgent Community response
teams which were encouraging there's
also the the work that we're doing
around estec which is same day emergency
care where patients can go directly when
we understand what their treatment needs
are they're less likely to be admitted
by going through that sort of process as
well so there's a number of different
factors that we try and take into place
can't avoid those situations and we've
heard about some of them in mental
health as well and some of the work and
investment that the ambulance service
are quite correctly doing around mental
health one of the things you haven't
mentioned though is Pharmacy and both
watching my mother's admission to
hospital uh earlier in the in the year
and watching her wait 12 hours for her
drugs to come up and as a clinician
myself seeing how long it takes
sometimes for drugs to come up for
patients to what extent does delays in
Pharmacy ttos as we'd call them
um contribute to this flow problem
through a e and therefore the ambulance
backlog
I think it's going to vary between
different hospitals I think most
Hospitals now would have situations
where you don't necessarily need to wait
the patient can go home when the drugs
can follow
um in in terms of being able to deliver
the drugs to patients and obviously
encouraging as you know our Junior
doctors and ourselves to make sure that
we've got the ttas written up in a
timely manner to make sure we get those
discharges and a real Focus for most
hospitals at the moment is around
discharging patients before 12 o'clock
especially those patients we know can go
home the same day and exactly for that
reason that what we want to do is to
release the beds to be able to bring
patients through and make sure that
we're not getting those under
unnecessary delays around ttas and
that's saying that each hospital is
absolutely focused on thank you also I
don't know Lincolnshire has this thing
called lives volunteers absolutely
fabulous service of people who go out in
sort of paramedic like cars essentially
providing um first first aid and First
Care to patients I don't know whether
that's widespread across the country or
how much that um can help support the
ambulance service yeah I'm happy to
comment first down I might want to come
and say yeah Community First Responders
are used up and down under the country
that's because for cardiac arrests uh
it's really important that somebody gets
there quickly who can do CPR and can use
a defibrillator and that doesn't need to
be a paramedic need to be followed up by
a paramedic once you've had that initial
response and that is what's happening so
uh every Ambulance Service in the United
Kingdom uses a scheme similar to lives
and they are very much therefore
critical patients where time at minutes
and seconds actually make a huge
difference and what that immediate
intervention isn't isn't the paramedic
that immediate intervention is someone
who is trained in that immediate life
support
if I could
um about the about the pay you're going
to come on to the industrial situation
next so if you can hold that I thought
that would be um wonderful but I am
going to come on to um Rachel Harrison
next as we move on to look at the
industrial situation tomorrow 10 000
workers uh going to walk out on on the
strike the the unions have said that
they want to talk to negotiate over pay
and this afternoon the unions will be
meeting with the Secretary of State over
the industrial dispute what are you
wanting to see as the outcome to that
meeting
well unfortunately we don't expect an
offer to be made on pay today we've been
given half an hour to meet with the
secretary of state to discuss
um emergency cover for tomorrow
um which considering our strike starts
at midnight is a bit late in the day and
but those agreements have already been
reached at a local level so
unless the secretary of state is willing
to talk to us about pay today those
strikes are set to go ahead now what
we've been calling on him to do is to
come to the table talk to the unions
make us an offer on pay that we can take
back to our members and they will be the
ones that determine whether that is a
good offer or a bad offer but that is
the quickest way to resolve this dispute
and we've been calling on the government
and the pay review bodies to recognize
NHS workers that for many years now and
for the last two years we've entered
into that process in good faith under an
extremely delayed timeline which
actually meant that the lowest paid in
the NHS this year had to have a Top-Up
given to their wages to prevent the
employers from breaching national
minimum wage rates
now due to the timeline that has been
given to the prb again this year we will
be in the same position so the national
living wage has now gone above the
minimum of these people working in the
NHS now these could be your call
handlers these could be your patient
transport and workers they're your
Porters possibly they're your cleaners
your Caterers these are people that
carry out crucial jobs within our NHS
and because of a dated and not fit for
purpose pay review body process that
significantly delays getting money into
people's pockets and the approach of
this government towards Public Service
cuts and austerity means that we have
got members working right across the NHS
on low pay and this is the exact reason
we're seeing them leave so I will plea
to the secretary of state is taught to
the unions about pay make as an offer
GMB is refusing to engage with the pay
review body this year because we believe
the government has hid behind that
recommendation that was made back in the
spring of this year
and and we believe that what we actually
need to see is true reform of the prb
process
where the Remake given doesn't tie the
prb's hands into existing budgets that
have already been set and existing bank
accounts that the trusts are already
struggling to manage and that the
independence on that panel and that they
are free to make recommendations that
considers things like the true cost of
living and the impacts on the workforce
so that's why we're calling for reform
we're asking the Secretary of State to
come to the table in the past the
government have moved away from the peer
review body process we had pay
negotiations in 2016 and we had to pay
negotiations in 2018 that the employers
and the Department of Health were
representative at and Jeremy Hunt
himself and in 2014 chose to ignore the
recommendation of the program so they
can step away from that recommendation
so what we're calling on the government
to do is talk to us make us an offer
that we can take back to our member
members because our members don't want
to strike they've been forced into this
so we're in the government have it
within their control to resolve this
issue and they could do that today
thank you ever so much Julian I just
want to ask you because we constantly
hear government ministers saying that
the pay-per-view body has
um sets the the
um the process stressing its
independence however government appoint
the members and set the remit Define
um the terms of affordability and
control when and how the recommendations
are published So within this situation
where we clearly have got a disparity in
in expectation between government and
the the workers here the independent pay
review body doesn't seem to have the
ability to make the recommendations of
what needs to be done to be able to
resolve this dispute so how do you see a
mechanism and a way forward to be able
to address that issue if the
pay-per-view body doesn't have that
power
obviously those are really questions for
government rather than for myself as
nhse
um obviously they're they're the ones
who Define those sort of those
parameters of pay so I think those
questions would need to be to the
government I mean I think what we're
concentrating on and I think all of us
even the Jimmy the constraint is to try
and ensure that we keep our patients as
safe as possible doing any industrial
action
um and obviously we respect the right
for people to take the industrial action
but we all are there to make sure that
we want the public to have confidence
and to be safe during those periods and
I'm sure that's something that we all
want to do and and if I may um to both
John and and Darren
um we've heard that um the impact of low
pay
um on on the workforce and this pay
dispute currently is having a massive
impact on Recruitment and Retention do
you concur with that and as a result of
that what else needs to be done to
address the the issues of recruitment
retention yeah so go to primary
professional body uh rather than a trade
Union so I'm not going to talk
specifically about terms and conditions
uh as I said earlier we don't have a
problem attracting people into the
profession and paramedic is a has a good
number of people coming in uh retaining
them in the profession is is much harder
I think that's partly for those who are
in ambulance services or members tell us
that uh this this impact and we've
talked about uh over over the last few
minutes is having on them but also
because paramedics as a profession have
got lots of opportunities now so we've
got them working in Primary Care um
we've got them working in emergency
departments I think that's good for
individuals it's good for longevity of
career difficult to be a Frontline
paramedic into your into your 60s
whereas maybe working in other settings
is possible so we've got primarily a
retention problem and some of the
salaries outside of the ambulance
service are are higher and more
attractive and
do you agree that uh
which needs a major issue and is pay a
factor in that
yeah so that's one of my biggest
concerns and I know what's the concern
from all the chief Executives as well is
the fact that it's not just about payers
we've already heard it's about the
working conditions that the ambulance
staff are working in and as John said we
don't have a problem recruiting and
training paramedics up across the
country necessarily but the challenge we
have in the ambulance sector as
paramedics now no longer want to
continue to work in the ambulance sector
they want to go and work in Primary Care
another your primary care and and I
don't know emergency departments and
other disciplines as opposed to working
in the ambulance sector and it's down
the hospital handlebuddly issue I think
it's one of those single causes of off
that so it's not just about paid I would
argue and I know I think everybody said
that to be fair
thank you very much Lucy thank you
um I wonder if I could start with you
Rachel about the impact on patients
tomorrow in in terms of patient safety
but also longer term impact uh on the
backlog that's already there
um how do you think that the action
tomorrow will impact patients
well first of all give gmb's assurance
that our GMB reps and local teams have
been working around the clock for the
last couple of weeks with local
employers to agree derogations and
exemptions and to make sure that
essential cover is in place and we have
entered into all of those conversations
in good faith
um I believe most agreements have now
been signed off
um and you know we're doing our role in
communicating to our members what what
they are and encouraging them to adhere
to the exemptions that have been put in
place it does vary the cover by um
service and the reason being is the
unions feel that the correct people
place to make the decisions as to what
care is needed in local communities is
the people working in those communities
and that's why we may see variances of
what those are Arrangements look like
but you know life and limb cover will be
provided the last thing that our members
want to do is put patients in harm way
but the reason We've Ended up in a
position of dispute now is because they
feel they're prevented from being
delivering patient care and we have to
realize that right now today people are
not getting the ambulances they are
taking themselves to hospitals in a taxi
because they can't get the ambulance you
know people are dying waiting to be
handed over at a e departments that's
happening today and that is one of the
very reasons that has driven us to this
dispute so we will do everything within
our power to ensure that communities are
safe during this action
the government has to play their part
they have to come to the table and talk
to us our members want a resolution to
this
redhead what steps have been taken to
reassure the public that all cat one and
Cat 2 will definitely be responded to
tomorrow thank you and obviously we're
very grateful to the members or the
member staff who will come to work and
use those derogations to do that I think
that that is important to recognize that
that as part of their strike action
um I think the what we've done is to
concentrate with our unions to make sure
that we have the services available for
those sickest and most vulnerable
patients to have the response that they
required and those in general will be in
category 1 and category two uh call out
categories there are others where there
may be elderly patients who are on the
on the floor for some time as well who
also may need care so that's why we're
working very hard with the unions to to
get those derogations obviously we've
also tried to support those services
with bringing in obviously there's the
military in some instances there are
other clinicians who are going to help
to try and make sure that those maintain
those safeties and the unions are aware
of those and are working with us to make
sure that they're integrated into the
care of our patients so I think the
overarching message is that emergency
care will continue we've heard about the
life and limb emergencies and that
shouldn't discourage us from dialing 999
if we feel that they that we that the
public feel that they need that service
they will be answered and an appropriate
response will be available when that's
required will patient safety be affected
tomorrow
I think that they we're doing everything
we can to maintain patient safety and
that's what we're concentrating all the
time and none of us I don't think any
member staff I know a lot of paramedics
would also say this nobody wants to see
Public Safety um
by this John can I ask you about that
about the Public's safety tomorrow and
and what your perception of it will be
yeah so I think um as I said earlier I
don't think safety is black and white
it's not one or the other um right now
today uh we're seeing long delays for
patients there's lots of patients uh
waiting at the moment to to for an
ambulance uh response uh on Wednesday
even with the derogations that's likely
to be likely to be worse
um but with this um life and limb cover
paramedics up and down the country will
absolutely want to keep patients safe I
think the important bit to note in that
though is
um the category one calls the ones that
come in at the time uh that look like
they are life and limb they they will
get a response and and we're working
um the unions are working very hard on
how that will occur it's the group who
are in category two and Below who maybe
don't start off a life in them and this
is what we're seeing today let alone
Wednesday who will deteriorate over time
and eventually they will become a life
or limb emergency and obviously at that
point then they do fall into together
but it's whether or not that's uh that
but that's happening today so it's gonna
be really clear that's happening today
um and that's what we see for the
category 2 response times that Rachel
mentioned earlier it was 48 minutes was
reported in um in November's figures
nationally that's that's twice as long
as it was a number of years ago and it's
those patients who are waiting and some
of those who are deteriorating uh we're
seeing that they then they then get
upgraded so you call back and you say
this has happened to me and and that
probably explains some of the shift in
in the category one numbers when we say
incidents are up so I think we need to
be clear that those who are in a life
and limit it's the ones um I think our
members are worrying about that that
aren't going to deteriorate over time
and and whether something can happen
with those but that's happening today uh
right now
um before we even get to Industrial
action on Wednesday thank you Darren can
I just ask you a final question about
addressing the issue of morale and
burnout amongst paramedics
how do you feel
what do you feel should be done to try
and assist
yes I think it's it's really really
difficult just now isn't it I think if I
think about the 31 years I've been in
the ambulance act on the 34 years in the
NHS I would say this is the most
difficult time I've experienced in a
number of my chief exec colleagues have
experienced as well and I know that's
how the staff feel because I speak to
them day and day out it has absolutely I
think been exacerbated
um on the back of covert there has been
no
um respite whatsoever and you normally
we would get respite in between the
peaks of the winter periods and a little
bit of respect before we went into busy
you know Summers and then back into
winter but if you think about covert
we've just had no respect whatsoever and
I think that's what's really seriously
affecting our morale of her of our staff
and that's why I'm really
um you know desperate to continue to
work with any single and Minister around
right sizing ambulance trusts so that we
can have the right level of resources to
respond to the new levels of Demand with
the new pressures that we see across the
ambulance sector continuing to to do all
the good things that we have been doing
with regards to hearing tree and scene
tree and I would like to see us build in
to some of those rotors and patterns
some more protective time after their
staff from us continuous professional
development point of view and from a
health and well-being point of view as
well and because that's what we need to
be doing and that's what I'll continue
to work with nhsc colleagues and
ministers on going forward
I think to 80.2 of an ambulance staff
are experiencing burnout so a really
important issue James if I can turn to
you just um just to Rachel I can't just
listen to what you said about the
there's a driver for the dispute I can't
work out whether it's about pay
I think you said it's about your members
being prevented from doing their job
which is it
the legal dispute is is fundamentally
about pay and ambulance workers pay has
been
um slashed in real terms and I think the
average is 13 it's been slashed and I
mentioned earlier about those in the
call centers and patient transport
services that have fallen below the
living wage so this is absolutely about
pay at the heart of this and it will be
an offer on paid that can resolve this
dispute but the reason our members have
chosen this year to ver for industrial
action is a build up of everything that
we've discussed today because it's not
just GMB members that have said enough
is enough all you have to do is look at
the 14 Health unions that are recognized
across the NHS and how many of those
have balloted their members this year
because they've been asked to ballot
their members by their members and how
many of those have secured mandates for
industry election that tells you the
strength of feeling across the entire
NHS and ambulance service Workforce
so patient safety standards are at the
heart but strength of feeling about what
we've got a we've got a health system
which is
being funded by 180 billion pounds by
2025. it's never had so much more money
everybody recognizes that covid
presented huge challenges to the health
system which were outside the control of
the government
um so the government has committed a
huge amount of additional resources to
the NHS at a time of severe challenge in
terms of recovering from the backlog
isn't this completely inappropriate time
for unions to be considering industrial
action
no this is the the ideal time because
this is our members saying enough is
enough now they will continue to leave
the service in their thousands if we
don't start to do something to address
their working conditions which is
agreeing to your pay demands is that
right is it is it's about pay so if the
government this afternoon we want to
keep membership if the secretary of
state was to agree to all your demands
this afternoon and we will walk away
from this then
um all of the issues that we've been
discussing today would be resolved
yeah absolutely not the service is still
in crisis that is no overnight solution
but one issue that will be resolved is
that our members will feel rewarded and
they will feel valued not only for the
last two years during the pandemic
efforts when they went to work and many
of them didn't go home because they had
insufficient PPE that this government
wasted money on contracts they were sent
to the front line without protections so
rightly so they have had enough so yes
pay is the crucial thing and that is the
legal dispute because we've got
hospitals setting up food banks how can
our pandemic Heroes be having to access
food banks not being able to put fuel in
their cars
what do you want so what GMB asked for
along with the majority of the other
unions at the time that we put our prb
submission in was an inflation busting
increase
a commitment trusting me
whatever inflation was at the time above
that
um an immediate
um plan to restore a decade of lost
earnings with a down payment so what
we're actually asking for now is an
immediate Solution on pay make us an
offer we will take that offer back to
our members and they will be the ones
that determine whether it's a sufficient
offer or not so we're not making a
demand we're saying make us an offer
okay thank you thank you
um
Rachel
what you said about the frustration and
what others have said about the
frustration of paramedics wanting to do
the job but being stuck outside an
Indian ambulance waiting is is very
powerful
um emotive response but but but like uh
James I am somewhat confused because
you said earlier it's not about to pay
it's about the response
and then you've said but if it gives me
an offer on pay today then
called off the strike
um and obviously calling giving if the
government's only got so much money and
it chooses so you say it's it's said
that 700 million pounds pays one percent
on agenda for change bands
if it has said if it found 700 million
would you want it to give that to your
union members in pay
or would you want it to invest in
perhaps additional space in a e so they
can more factually do their job by
getting back on the road quicker
as we've said there's no overnight
solution to the crisis in our Health
Service and social care absolutely not
and it needs a lot of investment and a
credible plan at the center of that
though is the workforce and what we are
seeing and it's being said today is that
we cannot keep staff
not only have has their pair been eroded
in real terms
their working conditions have been
severely eroded earning capacity on
things like on social hours has been
taken away from 2018. so people are
leaving because they can go to primary
care or to GP Services where the
pressures are a lot less demanding there
are no unsocial hours and they don't
have to spend their entire shift in the
back of ambulances we've got Stu try to
interrupt you but you didn't really
answer the question because I understand
it so
if the government's got 700 million
pounds and it has it wants to choose to
spend it on investments in capacity in a
e or flows in Social care or things that
will make the working lives of your
members less frustrating so that's like
to get stuck outside a e or spend on
what an extra one percent which should
the government choose which field
members want more less frustrating job
or more money
if they they want to be able to do their
job so you absolutely government and
invest it not in the pay but in in stuff
that makes the job easier to do that
they need investment in their pay if we
are to keep them there's no point having
extra beds and extra Services if there
are no staff to to run those Services
that's the ambulance service and it's
the NHS we need investment in the
workforce now and at the center of that
is pay because if we continue to lose
the existing staff all the recruitment
drives that have been happening at the
moment are pointless if we cannot hold
on to our existing staff
there will be no NHS and there will be
no ambulance services so we have to
invest right now in the workforce and
sit and have a proper conversation about
how we tackle the crisis and that's got
to involve social care as well because
we cannot get people out of hospitals if
the care isn't out there in the
community okay so it's pay so do do you
support nurses requests for 19.6 do you
think is that the sort of pay rise that
you're looking at GMB didn't ask for 19
I'm conscious that at the time RCM put
their submission into the pay review
body they asked for RPI plus five
percent as I said earlier we've not
asked for 19 we've asked for inflation
busting and what we're asking for right
now is a conversation on pay and to make
us an offer okay so you're not happy
with the the independently verified
offer independent review offer but you
want a better offer I understand that
um
but
there's some kind of discussion and you
see it in the media they talk about
nurses pay ambulance drivers pay
paramedics pay but actually all this pay
is one one scheme isn't it so you have
the agenda for change bands and if
you're not a doctor a dentist or an
extremely senior manager in the NHS
you're all paid in uh one of nine bands
as some division of band a but
essentially one of night bands so a
newly qualified nurse newly qualified
paramedic are both paid band five so
there is actually no capacity
to pay permatics and nurses differently
unless you change the bands that they're
in so if you're not asking for as much
as the nurses do you and you support the
nurse's request do you think that
paramedics ambulance technicians and
core handlers are in the wrong agenda
for change bands at the moment do you
think their work is equipped more
equivalent to a higher working higher
band or do you think they're they're
banding's right but the pay for each
banding is wrong
I think there's a huge issue with pay
banding across the whole of the NHS in
all of the professions and there's a
large piece of work being undertaken at
the moment and with the ambulance
service profiles and also the nurses and
the Midwife profiles but that will not
solve the issue the real issue is that
people are being expected to work
regardless of their job expected to work
under extremely different circumstances
than when their job was initially
evaluated and what we're also seeing is
that those people that have stuck with
the NHS are having to pick up the
workload of the 133 000 people that
aren't there so all of the workers in
the NHS are working under extreme
pressures and we would be calling on all
employers to review all of the jobs
because we definitely recognize that
people are not being paid the correct
rate for the job in all in all
professions the the agenda for changing
bands have been instances negotiated
with the last Labor government 2004 and
the unions themselves and the unions
wanted them at the time because they
felt they could then make sure that
equivalent jobs were paid in the
equivalent manner are you suggesting
that your members would now want to see
dismantling of agenda for change that
paramedics and ambulance staff are paid
in in a different set of negotiations to
nurses to managers to Porters to clean
us and everyone else or do you want them
we're not suggesting walking away from
agenda for change what what we're saying
has happened is that the jobs have
changed drastically since they were
initially evaluated so it needs a whole
refresh and a whole evaluation so we're
not suggesting walk away we're still
supportive at this time of the agenda
for Change and that encompassing all the
professions within that
okay so it's more a case of you think
the bandlings of the jobs are not quite
right anymore people aren't being paid
the correct way that Healthcare
assistant is a good example we have a
lot of healthcare assistants that are
paid at a band too whereas more and more
medical
um treatments have slipped into their
job roles which means they should be
getting paid a band three and in many
places we're struggling to get them
uplifted to the band three to truly
reflect the job that they are now being
required to perform okay fair enough the
other thing is you talked about a decade
of lost earnings and I was confused with
that and I got some figures looking at
bands three five and six between 2005
which is essentially just after the
agenda for change came in and 2021 and
in all cases band Three band five and
band Six the proportion of median
earnings that is earned by each of those
people is higher now than it was in
2005. so when we ask taxpayers to pay
the salaries of the over a million
people on agenda for change pay and the
government say one percent on a gender
for change pay band is 700 million
pounds about 700 million pounds has to
come from The Wider population in taxes
and when we do that we take that from
people whose earnings have risen in line
with mostly private private sector and
wage increases
um and we look at the median the middle
number of the salaries of the whole time
equivalent median and gross earnings and
actually for band Three band five and
band Six which is the ones that we
looked at so your call Handler your
newly qualified paramedic and your fully
trained has been never a while paramedic
um the proportional meeting average
earnings that they earn now is higher
than it was a decade and more ago so
where's the decade of lost earnings if
your if your weight your members wages
are reasonably increasing in line with
the wages of the general populace
well the way faster than the general
populace I've obviously not seen your
your statistics that you're referring to
there but but on the calculations that
we've done it's the real-time earnings
as then they've not kept up with
inflation so every single pay review
body recommendation we've had since uh
2010 I think it has been below the level
of inflation so in real terms our
members pay is not keeping up in the
ambulance service on average it's it's
13 but also what's not generally
included in in statistics like the ones
you're quoting at me is acknowledgment
of the fact that for our ambulance
service members a lot of their
um take-home pay is built around their
own social hours which again was cut in
2018
um and a lot of them rely on on overtime
and to be the ambulance services cannot
function without the Goodwill of our
members that do overtime so it's
difficult to comment on on statistics
like that because they don't necessarily
take account of the full picture of what
our members are earning but but I
remember members are seeing real-term
losses
because of inflation and cost of living
and they are taxpayers themselves so any
increase they will be paying more tax
back to the system as well so
what happens if um you know if the
government say look even one percent 700
million we can't select our paramedics
we can't select down nurses it's agenda
for change pay bands they have to be the
whole NHS has to be paid that amount of
money across the board it's unaffordable
um
are you going to continue to strike I'll
be our patients going to have to suffer
what would you do if they say no I'm
sorry we just we just don't have the
money to afford this our members will be
the ones that decide they're the ones
that have voted for Action they are the
ones that have determined what action we
will take and when we will take it we
will continue to say to the government
our door is open to talk about pay our
members will be the ones that decide on
any payoffer that is made and if no
payoff for his forth come in we will
continue to have that conversation next
year as we head towards the next round
of of paid discussions as well and
perhaps I could just ask Darren and John
there's um there's paramedics themselves
um if the government's got 700 million
pounds to invest does it invest one
percent in your in your pay and your
colleagues pay or does it invest 700
million pounds in a e capacity social
care capacity and other things that make
the job a more
um rewarding and and fulfilling
experience
Darren first
I think
um in terms of the one percent uplift of
whatever it may or may not be that is
really a matter for the peer review body
and and government isn't it you know I
could give a an opinion here around what
I think it should or shouldn't be you
know we know what's happened in Scotland
don't we because I used to work there
for many many years so I've got a lot of
contacts up there I think it's very
difficult I think
um you know some Association of
ambulance chief executive point of view
I keep coming back to the work that
we're doing with anything just now on
right sizing our organizations so if
there is some money available to go into
the ambulance sector to do just that I
think that will help all of our
ambulance sector colleagues and all of
our staff but payers are really a matter
for government impair of your body thank
you leader Joe
so our members will definitely say
working life will be better if there
were less Hospital Handover delays if
when they went to refer a patient in the
community that the service was available
uh Etc so that that would make a huge
difference but I'm not sure this is an
overall choice because at the same time
not retaining paramedics in the
ambulance sector as well as in in other
parts of the NHS that primates are
working if pay is important to them as I
referring to that we're a professional
body not a trade Union if pay is
important to retention to lose our
experienced paramedics either to not be
a paramedic any longer or to other parts
is hugely damaging so then you might
well have better referral Pathways less
Handover delays but you won't have a
Workforce left so as it is a matter for
government to decide what what are the
choices and which ones we're making but
our members would definitely be saying
that they uh they want a better a better
ability to deliver care as paramedics
thank you thank you very much can I just
uh say thank you ever so much for coming
along today John Martin down in mockery
uh Professor Julian redhead and Rachel
Harrison
um it's been a really enlightening
session we hope the talks this afternoon
are constructive and we look forward to
seeing the national strategy when it is
published and we hope that's soon order
order
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much